I feel very secure in my personhood you
know I mean I've always felt secure in
my ability but you don't know if anybody
else sees your ability right off yeah
I've had directors tell me to do stuff
on screen that I knew was wrong and you
try to tell them it's not right
so rather than create a schism say okay
I'll do one for you and I'll do one for
me and if they do bad and they're not
looking at this little monitor they see
it on the big screen they come back and
they'll tell you you're right first
stage play I did in New York I was
working with Stacy Keach that was a
great experience for me she talked about
a master class you have it there other
states had come out of Yale University I
think and I was much more vast as a
stage actor than I was but Wow did I
have big ears and was I ready to learn
so you just sit and watch it's always a
learning experience the big thing I
learned from working with Pearl Bailey
was professionalism
she was total professional total total
total professional she always gave 100
percent 110 percent and a performance
and I watched her very carefully she was
one of those
a formless that you say this is the way
to go this is the way to be in this
business beyond time know what you're
doing do it fall out give all you can
and so that's a lesson you just watched
two amazing clips of Morgan Freeman take
the next three minutes to sit quietly
and think about how you can apply them
to your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]